[Music]
here we go
you'll love this story is standing up
someone on a date i don't know worth
filing a lawsuit over
one michigan woman apparently thinks yes
it is she sued her one-time prospective
suitor for ten thousand dollars she sued
somebody that stood her up on a date
kashante short claims intentional
infliction of emotional distress
saying that richard jordan hurt her
because he did not show up it happened
to be her mother's birthday and her
mother had just passed away now during a
recent
why would you go on a date on but then
[Music]
getting stood up
it happens sometimes right
last part of life
a court appearance on zoom jordan said
this was a waste of the court's time and
that he's simply being sued because of a
bad date
to be honest with you sir i i thought
this was just going to be thrown out uh
it was we had a date
one date and nothing else after that do
not assault my intelligence as if i do
not understand what the word perjury
means
oh i need the full i need this
this was a world star i want her
screaming at the
judge do not insult my intelligence as
if i do not understand what the word
perjury means be quiet while i'm talking
oh my gosh
this woman this man dodged a bullet
oh my gosh that was her screaming at the
judge
there's got to be a video of just this
interaction there has to be this guy
i think i found it okay please
oh my g the judge by the way the judge
looks like who's that black guy that's
always on the news like that black power
guy with the fro the professor um
someone don't know
uh show links thank you
it's nine minutes holy [ __ ] all right
i'll skip around but i need i need to i
need to
i'm looking here yeah
yeah what is it intentional affliction
of emotional distress
yes is that the claim
yes it is that's
that's not something that's really
dismissible in district court
i'm sorry i can't hear you
i said that's not something that's
justiceable
in district court that has to be brought
in circuit court
so you said it's not permissible and
district court it has to be um taken to
circuit court
that's an equitable action yes
so it says he's trying to explain that
she can't sue for inten uh intentional
infliction of emotional people jordan
let me just ask you this are you
planning to
uh represent yourself on this
uh
i i
to be honest with you sir i i thought
this was just going to be thrown out as
any normal human would by the way uh it
was we had a date
one date and nothing else after that and
now i'm being sued for 10 000
it was
i don't real see how this is going to go
any further i think it's a waste of your
time
the problem is this
you know if you think it should be
dismissed you know you need to file the
appropriate motion you need to follow
motion to ask for that
letter in that letter he he lied
and then that's what brought forth the
perjury it was never perjury in the
beginning it was for perjury after his
response
well you can't you can't say listen he
has
he has the right to put whatever is in
the answer
i'm
because you don't like or you disagree
with what is in his answer
if he respond and his response is a lie
it's perjury then my documents will
prove that he lied in his room no
no
no this is not
yelling at a judge
i i like it yet she's she's got some uh
she's [ __ ] nuts this guy does
do you understand what perjury is
yes
obviously not that's a week he is a lie
i know it's like part of my name oh here
we go
here we go
[Music]
bottom line is you said it's a criminal
event so i will send it to circuit court
are we done here
wow um
ma'am
this wow
she's [ __ ] crazy
yeah this [ __ ] guy is like yeah you
the best thing this guy ever did was not
go on that date oh no this is someone
who be she's saying he raped him i'm
telling you this has that this is a fake
rape energy you could tell
you don't you don't understand man
he took his mask off he's done oh my god
here are we done here perjury quest
love's not happy
i don't know exactly what perfectly
means i know what history means
are we done criminal offense or not what
statement i don't see anything in the
complaint that says he
smiles
yeah dicky jordan over here know he's
going to win that's why
[Laughter]
he's like it was at this point i decided
to just shut the [ __ ] up
best decision that guy's ever made
honestly i'm just gonna shut the [ __ ] up
grandpa once told me stay quiet old
dicky stay quiet you'll know
when because you don't know what
happened you're on the outside looking
in
she's about to call she's about to call
him a racial slur and you know he she is
you don't know anything but you're
unplanned
whatever you are
no we're not this guy's not going to
release her now now he's going to make
her [ __ ] listen pardon me oh my god
allege this in the complaint you have
not
insulted my intelligence
it's not he's
i hope he goes listen stupid
ma'am you're doing a zoom court case at
the mall
i don't have to insult your intelligence
oh [ __ ]
man there's so borrow behind you
dude it's either a mall or a [ __ ]
airport terminal it's not about that you
you you don't i don't think you
understand what perjury is it's a false
statement
are we done here
i said no
i said no oh i like that this guy's not
letting it go now i wouldn't either
right
now do not do that
do not do that do not insult my
intelligence as if i do not understand
what the word perjury means
ma'am i have a feeling you don't
understand a lot of words
do not if it's a criminal offense then
it's a criminal office
ma'am ma'am are you aware that you're
wearing frames
[Laughter]
well ma'am it should not have been filed
in district court if you wanted
attention for some emotional distress
okay so that's a criminal offense do you
want are you are you going to dismiss it
and refile no i'm not
no i'm not going to dismiss it i will
file another case
this guy's
you can't have two cases going on the
same issue
well i'm not well i'm not
i'm not dismissing the case
okay
all right but you don't you wouldn't
have dismissed it anyway ma'am
if you want to discriminate that's up to
you but i as a plaintiff am not
dismissing the case
he has to make a proper motion
well that's on him
but i can also transfer the venue to
circle
yes that's what i thought because there
were other cases that should have been
transferred somewhere else
so that's okay
okay
i'm going to do that
oh did you hear that okay
is that okay i'm gonna do that i wonder
what he's gonna do
i i'm really wondering
because if he kicks it to circuit and
she perjured herself then she's going to
[ __ ] jail i hope she'll if she's
she's not going to but i mean i hope so
ma'am what about his what about his
costs
associated with appearing because you
filed it in the wrong court
uh-oh um
i need to see the
uh
is that what he's doing oh you're right
he's getting court cut
okay hold on i need to see because i was
not aware since you said perjury was not
on there i was not aware that a criminal
offense for intentional infliction of
emotional distress was considered a
criminal offense there that it had to be
can this guy the guy homie hasn't said a
word
he has to do now is shut up yeah he's
golden you got this bud the criminal you
stated that emotional infliction of
emotional distress is a criminal offense
and you stated that he's taking a sip
out of his drink
perjury is a criminal offense but you
also stated that criminal that perjury
is not on the document that i place
forth before you so criminal offense
would not it's not in the competition
i need you no i need you to show me
i need you to show me the document which
states that
intentional affliction of emotional
distress is indeed and in fact a
criminal offense because that's the
original offense that was placed on
there i know you said that
i never said ejaculation of the perjury
will cause the
uh anal uh
fortitude uh excuse me
magnitude
and living
doesn't mean color was so bad yes you
did i never said that yes you did no i
did not
yes you did listen listen listen i'm not
going to sit here and go back and forth
with you i will repeat to you wow you're
right there's no glasses in those frames
they're just frames
that's right why you think i'm at the
mall [ __ ] i'm going to
lencecrafters
what i said i'm not either
that intentionally
you commuter is still here and and she
could hear you
what i said was what i said was
intentional infliction she's still
talking but she's muted is something
that circuit court has jurisdiction over
i never characterized that as a criminal
matter it is definitely
a civil claim but it is something that
can't be done
she's still talking now that's that's
what i said to you
you are on the mistaken belief that
circuit court does not hear
civil matters because you said well i
thought circuit court only did criminal
you were the one who were mistaken
on a circuit court docket she's been
going for a criminal charge
all right
hold on
um
where's
[Music]
home on airbnb i'm just trying to i'm
trying to see if i can get back to just
the the news story
here it is so at least i i don't want to
i just want to see what happened
oh my so short has been ordered to pay
all fees and expenses for the hearing
the judge
that's what she did that's what he did
case to be moved to a different court
system
it's really the wildest thing i think
i've seen one of the top 10 at least in
one of these zoom cases she's yelling at
the judge and the judge i would i would
argue that cat filter guy was the best
zoom meeting thing that we've ever
written she's never going to be better
than cat lawyer yeah i don't know how to
turn it off i'm not a cat
and the fact that the filters are made
to reflect whatever you're doing yeah
look the cat looked horrified
the cat was sad
the cat was all horrified and like oh
god oh no
she's like he committed perjury he lied
and the judge is trying to explain no
perjury is when you lie on the stand
when you're testifying and she's like i
know what perjury is he lied and the
judge is like regardless
this is a criminal court this needs to
be filed in civil court like basically
send this to somebody else
it was wild but you know what he
shouldn't be lying
what do you mean
but what
oh what
i think she's [ __ ] what i think she's
trying to be funny all right let's see
let's see let's see
she should be like should she sue over
there no he shouldn't be lost
okay she is she is dead
why did i even you know i shouldn't be
lying i also understand why he didn't
show up right exactly you shouldn't be
lying okay
merge please don't fall in love